[Music]
heard a lot about this idea that peanut
butter can act as a cheap replacement or
moisturizing the shaving cream
today we're shaving with peanut butter
and they're a bunch of YouTube videos
spanning me is I have this thing and
they're like it's a hack it's a hot I
love peanut butter it feels really good
on my skin I must admit I do I usually
do and I show you
oh oh okay mmm Wow I don't know I mean
it's working I put way too much on
immediate thought suppose oh it's smooth
it's always getting stuck oh now it's
not really doing anything maybe you need
less peanut butter then what I have on I
used way too much as I'm putting the
slack to moisturize this bottom leg okay
can you see that
this is lump of peanut butter like
spilling out of the race huh
the mixed foul it's a bit thick and it's
kind of going into my razor right now so
I mean it feels like it's dragging but
it is working I mean that feels pretty
smooth probably missed but we have too
much a little bit goes a long way with
this so my theory is that you're using
that peanut butter to kind of grease
your arm but it's just like an oily pain
that's lovely
only thing I would say is it down point
I can't stop touching my leg like it's
really not what money you would save not
getting shaving cream you would end up
spending on razors so it just depends on
what you want Vino's two bucks more and
rather just get that and not clog my
eights pink that being said like it
feels really nice it's like more silky
than one I use shave gel because I feel
like it's moisturize being more than
shave gel does which is insane but super
messy and gross
[Music]